okay welcome back everyone
this is the second lecture on machine
learning so just before we get started a
couple of announcements
homework one foundations is due tomorrow
at 11 p.m. note that it's 11 p.m. not
11:59 and please I would recommend
everyone try to do a test mission early
right it would be unfortunate if you
wait until 10 59 and you realize that
your computer you can log into the
website
if that happens please don't just
bombard me or or with yeah so just to
remind you are responsible for any
technical issues you encounter so please
do the test submission early so you have
a peace of mind and then you can go back
to finishing your peer homework ok
homework 2 sentiment is out this is the
homework on machine learning and it will
be due next Tuesday
and finally there's a section this
Thursday which we'll talk about back
propagation and nearest neighbors and
maybe a overview of scikit-learn which
might be useful for your project so
please come to that
ok so let's jump in I'm gonna spend a
few minutes reviewing what we did last
time kind of starting at the very
abstract level and drilling down into
the details so abstract level learning
is about taking a data set and
outputting a predictor F which will be
able to take inputs X for example an
image and output a label or output Y for
example whether it's a cat or a truck or
so on and if you unpack the learner we
talked about how we want to frame it as
a optimization problem which captures
what we want to optimize what properties
the predictor F should satisfy apart
from the optimization algorithm which is
how we accomplish our objective
so the optimization problem that we
talked about last time was minimizing
the training loss and in symbols this is
the training loss which depends on a
particular weight vector is the average
over all examples in a training set of
the loss of that particular example with
respect to the weight vector W okay and
we want to find the W that minimizes the
training loss so we want to find the
single W that makes sure's on average
all the examples have low loss okay so
looking at the loss functions now this
is where it depends on what we're trying
to do if we're doing regression then the
pertinent thing to look at is the
residual which remember is the models
prediction - the truth label so this is
kind of how much we overshoot and the
loss is going to be zero if the residual
is zero and increases either
quadratically for the square loss or
linearly for the absolute deviation
depending on how much we want to
penalize large deviations for
classification or binary classification
more specifically the pertinent quantity
you look at is a margin which is the
score times of the label Y which
remember is plus 1 or minus 1 so the
margin is a single number that captures
how correct we are so large margin is
good in that case we obtain either a
zero or near zero loss and margin lesson
zero means that we're making a mistake
so the zero and lost captures that we're
making a mistake of a lost one but the
hinge loss in the logistic lost kind of
grow linearly because allows us to
optimize the function better question
yeah
the lost squared curve there with the
residual will be the residual looks like
on the graph here we just feel away from
there
so there are multiple graphs here so
remember last time we looked at the
residual if you look at X or a rather
fee of X over Y so here's a line here is
a particular point V of X V of X Y and
the residual is that basically the
difference between the models prediction
and the actual point here this graph is
different this graph is visualizing in
is in a different space right I'll show
you another graph that might make some
of these things okay I guess one way to
think about the residual is the residual
is a number so if your residuals to then
you're kind of it here and this is the
loss that you pay which is two in this
case and if the residual is -2 then you
pay - yeah the residual is the x-axis
and the margin is x-axis over here okay
any other questions about this
you know what the question is one would
you use the absolute value versus the
square loss there is a slide from the
previous lecture which I skipped over
which talks about when you would want it
most of the time people you tend to use
the square loss because it's easier to
optimize but you also see absolute you
know deviation the the square loss will
penalize large outliers a lot more which
means that it has kind of mean mean like
qualities whereas the absolute deviation
panels are less so it's more like a
median just for kind of intuition but
the general point is out all these loss
functions capture properties of a
desired predictor they basically say
hand me a predictor and I'll try to
assess for you how good this is right
this is kind of establishing what we
want out of it and you know also another
comment is that you know I'm presenting
this loss minimization framework because
it is so general anything basically that
you see in machine learning can be
viewed as some sort of no loss
minimization if you think about PCA or
deep neural networks different types of
auto-encoders they can all be viewed as
some sort of loss function which you're
trying to minimize so that's why I'm
kind of keeping this framework somewhat
general okay so let's go the opposite
direction of generality let's look at a
particular example and try to put all
the pieces together so suppose we have a
simple regression problem we have three
training examples 1 0 the output is 2 1
0 the output is 4 and 0 1 output is
minus 1 right so how do we visualize
what learning on this training set looks
like so let's try to form the training
loss the training loss remember is the
average over the losses on if each
individual example so let's look at the
losses on individual examples so we're
doing linear regression so an X is two
dimensional and fiha
x equals x so in this example so we're
basically trying to fit two numbers W 1
and W 2 so if you plug in these values
for x and y into this loss function then
you get the following quantities so the
dot product between W and X is just W 1
right because X X 2 is 0 and u minus 2
and you square it because we're looking
at the square loss the same thing for
this point instead of 2 you have a 4 and
that for this point WV of X minus y is W
2 now because now the X 2 is active
minus -1 squared ok so these are the
individual loss functions each of which
tells what I kind of want out of W so if
here I'm looking at this if W 1 is 2
then that's great I get a loss of 0 this
one says if W 1 is 4 that that's great
and I get a loss of 0 and obviously you
can't have both and the goal of the
training loss is trying to look at the
average so that you can pick one W that
works for as kind of on average is good
for all the points ok so now this is a
function in two dimensions it depends on
W 1 and W 2 so let me try to draw this
on the board to give you some more
intuition what this looks like
ok so I'm gonna draw W 1 W 2 and so the
first function is W 1 minus 2 okay so so
what is this function want to do it
wants W want to be close to or close to
2 and it doesn't care about W 2 right so
I'm not really sure how to draw this
function but it really requires
something in 3d so you can think about a
ball shape kind of coming out of the
board like this if this direction is
meant to be the the loss okay so I'm
gonna try to do well let's let's try it
this way so it's going to be like a kind
of a bunch of parabolas that look like
this coming out of the board
okay okay so what about the second one
the second one is w1 minus four squared
so that's going to be basically the same
thing but kind of centered around four
so route this axis
[Music]
okay so again this is gonna be some
problem coming out of the board and then
finally the other point is w2 minus
minus one so it's going to be happiest
when W 2 is minus 1 so it's going to be
kind of a bunch of you know parabolas
coming out of the board here okay so you
add all three functions up and what do
you get you get something that is has
first of all where do you think the
minimum should be intersections yeah
thank you the first I like the first
vertical and all the second oh the red
lines I mean oh yeah it's gonna be some
sort of intersection here so if you look
at the W 2 axis right it should
definitely be minus 1 because this is a
function that cares about W 1 so it's
gonna be somewhere here and both by
symmetry well this one wants it to be a
2 this one that wants to be a 4 so the
average is somewhere between you can
work all this kind of actually
mathematically out I'm just kind of
giving the rough intuition and now let
me draw the level curves here the level
curves are going to be something like
this where again if you're drawing in 3d
it's like a parabola or coming out of
the board here where here is the lowest
point and as you venture away from this
point your loss is going to increase
right
okay yeah how do I get this middle point
so one way is that if you add these two
functions up and kind of just you know
plot it it turns out to be a three
incredibly the the square loss when your
average it acts kind of like a mean so
kind of you know it's going to be
somewhere between there's also related
to one of the homework problems so
hopefully you'll have a better
appreciation for that okay so so I guess
yeah question once we have the three how
are you merge it with the negative one
as well do we need to do another issue
um so question is once we have the three
how do you merge it with a minus one so
the three is regarding w1 and the minus
one is regarding w-2 so you just add
them together they kind of don't in this
particular example they don't interact
in general they will could you quickly
summarize that me what's going on with
this example
yeah so this plot shows for every
possible weight vector W 1 W 2 you have
a point and the amount that the function
comes out of the board is the loss right
and the loss function is defined on in
the slides right there and all I'm doing
is trying to plot this loss function so
unfortunately it's hard to kind of draw
in 3d here so what I'm trying to do here
is taking each of the pieces and trying
to explain what each piece is trying to
do all right
[Music]
so in general the the training loss you
don't have to think about kind of how
exactly it composes the individual
losses this is probably as complex of
example we'll have to you know get to
write to understand it but this kind of
gives you an idea of how you connect
these pictures where you see kind of
these parabolas with the picture which
is actually the of the you know training
loss okay but for now let's assume you
have a training loss it's a function of
the parameter it's some function and how
do you optimize this function so you do
some sort of gradient descent so last
time we talked about how you can just do
vanilla gradient descent where you
initialize with zero and then you
compute the grading of the entire
training loss and then you update once
and the problem with that is the up
computing the gradient requires going
through all the training examples you
have a million training example that's
really slow so instead we looked at
stochastic gradient descent which allows
you to pick up an individual example and
then make a gradient step right away
right and empirically we saw encode how
it can be a lot faster you know of
course there are cases where it can also
be less stable so there's kind of in
general going to be some you know
trade-off here but by-and-large
sarcastic waiting to send it
kind of really dominates you know
machine learning applications today
because you there's the only way to
really have scale to large data sets
okay yeah
[Music]
so apart from being able to scale up is
there any advantage of sarcastic
gradient descent another besides
computation
another advantage might be that your
data might be coming in online fashion
like over time and you want to you know
update kind of on the fly so there are
cases where you don't actually have all
the data at once okay so that was a
quick overview of the general concepts
now to set the stage for what we're
gonna do in this lecture I want to ask
you guys a following question
so can we obtain decision boundaries
remember a decision boundary is the the
kind of line that or the curve that
separates the region of the space which
is classified positively versus
negatively can we have paint decision
boundaries which are circles by using
linear classifiers okay so does that
make sense so we want to get something
like this where you have now we're going
into v1 of X you know feed two of X and
we want to decision boundaries that look
like this where you classify maybe these
as positive and these as negative okay
is that possible yeah you map if you
make a square of those inputs and you
get something it should be linear so
you're saying yes okay
[Music]
okay well there is a punchline there so
it turns out that you can actually do
this which maybe on the surface seems
kind of surprising right because we're
talking about linear classifiers but as
we will see it really depends on what
you mean by linear classifiers and
hopefully that would become clear sir
okay so we're going to start by talking
about features which is going to be able
to answer this question then we're going
to shift gears a little bit and talk
about neural networks which is in some
sense of automatic way to learn features
then we're gonna show you how to train
neural networks using back propagation
hopefully without tears and and then
talk about nearest neighbors which is
another way to get really expressive
models which is going to be a much
simpler in a way okay so recall that we
have the score so the score is a dot
product between the wave vector and a
feature vector and the score drives
prediction so if you're doing regression
you just output the score as a number if
you're doing classification binary
classification then your output the sign
of the score and so far we focus on
learning which is how you choose the
wave vector based on a bunch of data and
how you optimize for that and so now
what we're gonna do is focus on V of X
and talk about how you choose these
features in the first place and this
actually featured and generated feature
extraction is you know such a really
critical important part of kind of a
machine learning pipeline which often
kind of gets neglected because when you
take a class you're saying okay well
there's some feature vector and then
let's focus on all these algorithms but
whenever you go and apply machine
learning the world feature extraction is
turns out to be kind of the main
bottleneck and neural nets can mitigate
this to some extent but you still it
doesn't completely make feature
extraction obsolete so recall that a
feature extractor takes an input such as
this the string and outputs a set of
properties which are useful for
prediction so
in this case it's a set of named feature
values okay and last time we didn't
really say much about this we just kind
of waved our hands as I okay here are
some features so you know in general how
do you approach this problem what
features do you include do you just like
start making them up and how many
features do you have we need maybe a
better organizational principle here
and you know in general feature engineer
is going to be someone over art so I'm
not going to give you a recipe but at
least some framework for thinking about
features so the first notion is a
feature template and a feature template
is informally just a group of features
are all computed in the same way this is
a kind of a somewhat antic but a kind of
you know a terminology point that I want
you all to kind of be aware of so a
feature template is basically a feature
name with holes so for example length
greater than blank so remember the
concrete feature is length greater than
ten now we're gonna say length greater
than blank or blank and replaced with
ten nine eight or any kind of number
it's a template that gives rise to
multiple features last week a character
is equals blank contains character blank
these are all examples of feature
templates so when you're going in your
project or whatever and you describe
your features I want you to think about
kind of drooping these features in terms
of know these blanks another example is
pixel intensity of position so even if
you have what you consider to be like a
raw input like an image right there's so
implicitly some sort of way to think
about it as a feature template which
corresponds to like the pixel intensity
of position blank comma blank is a
feature template guy gives a rise to the
number of features equals to the number
of pixels in the image and this is
useful because maybe your input isn't
just an image maybe it's in it's an
image plus some metadata then having
this kind of language for describing all
the features in a unified way is really
important for clarity
okay so as I alluded to each feature
template maps to a set of features so by
writing last three characters equals
blank
I'm implicitly saying well I'm going to
define a feature for each value of blank
and that feature is going to be
associated with a value which is just
the natural evaluation of that feature
on the input okay so all of these are 0
except for ends with com is 1 okay so
and in general you are going to have
each feature template game might give
rise to many many you know features
write the number of possible 3 detector
is you know some number of characters to
the cube which is a large number so one
question is how do you represent this
right yes first vector yeah good answer
so mathematically it's really useful
just think about this vector as a
d-dimensional vector right just deed
numbers just laid out right and because
that's mathematically convenient but
when you go to actually implement this
stuff you might not represent things
that way in particular
you know what are the ways you can
represent a vector well you can say I'm
going to represent it as an array which
is just this list of numbers that you
have but this is inefficient if you have
a huge number of features but in the
cases where you have sparse features
which means that only a very few of the
feature values are nonzero then you're
better off representing as a a map or in
Python a dictionary which you specify
the feature name is a key and the value
is you know the value of that feature
right and all the the the homework two
will basically work in this sparse
feature you know framework
you know just a kind of a note a lot of
you know especially in NLP and we have
discrete objects um traditionally it's
been common to use kind of these sparse
feature maps you know one thing that has
happened with the rise of neural
networks is that often you take
basically your inputs and embed them
into some sort of fixed dimensional
vector space and dense feature
representations have been more you know
dominant but you know sports features if
you want to use linear classifiers is
still kind of a good way to go so it's
important to understand this okay so now
in sort of storing possibly a lot of
features now you just sports store the
the key and the value
all right so this was the feature
templates the overall point is I just
kind of organizational principle and you
know okay so now let's switch gears a
little bit
so what features or feature templates
should you actually you know write down
and to get at that I want to introduce
another notion which is you're pretty
important especially if you can
understand if you think about the theory
of you know machine learning and that's
a notion of a hypothesis class okay so
remember we have this predictor so for a
particular weight vector that defines a
function that map's inputs into you know
some sort of score or prediction in a
hypothesis class is just the set of all
predictors that you can get if you vary
the wave vector okay so so let me give
you I'm gonna come back to this slide
let me give you a kind of a example here
so suppose you're doing a regression and
you're doing you know linear regression
in particular
so you learn one dimension here is X and
here is you know I guess Y so if your
feature map is just identity so Maps X
to X then this notation just means the
set of all you know linear functions
like this then the set of functions you
get you can visualize as this right so
you have you know one function here and
for every possible value of w1 you have
a slope you can also have 0 they should
all go through the origin and so you
have you know these are your functions
right so your hypothesis class f1 here
is essentially all lines that go through
the origin so just want to think about
you when you write down a feature vector
you're implicitly committing yourself to
saying hey I want to think about all
possible predictors defined by this
feature map ok so here's another example
suppose I define the feature map to be x
comma x squared ok so now what are the
possible functions you know I'm gonna
get so does anyone want to say would
have read off this slide what it is
it's gonna be all quadratic functions
right okay so in particular because I
don't have a bias term it's going to be
all choreography I go through the origin
so let me actually draw another okay so
it's going to be all quadratic functions
that go through the origin which look
like this
there could be upside down and maybe
like that I'm not going to draw all of
them in particular it also includes the
linear functions right because I can
always set w2 equals 0 and very w1 which
means that I also get all the linear
functions too right so this means that
the two if you think about the set of
functions is a larger set than f1 it's
more expressive that's we mean by
expressive that means they can represent
more things okay so for every feature
vector
you should think also about the set of
functions that you can get by that you
know feature vector okay so let's lose
your question
[Music]
22 cents to find the best set of w's are
the more expressive sets harder the
question is are the more expressive sets
hard to optimize in terms of you know
the short answer is not necessarily
in terms of sure you have more features
so that require is more expensive yeah
at that level but the difficulty
optimization depends on a number of
different no factors and sometimes
adding more features can be easier to
optimize because it's easier to figure
training data okay so now let's go back
to this picture okay so this is on the
Border's concrete example as a feature
or hypothesis classes now let's think
about this big blob as the set of all
predictors any predictor in your wildest
dreams you know there in this this set
okay and whenever you go and you define
a feature map that's going to carve out
a you know a much smaller set of you
know functions right and and then what
is learning doing learning is choosing a
particular element of that function
family based on the data okay so this
picture shows you kind of the full
pipeline of how you're doing machine
learning is you know they're you first
declare structurally a set of functions
that you're interested in and then you
say okay now based on data let me go and
search through that set and find the one
that is you know best for me okay so now
there are you know two places where
things can go wrong well for feature
extraction maybe you didn't have enough
features so now your your your purple
set is too small then no matter how much
learning you do you're just not going to
get good accuracy right and then
conversely even if you define a nice you
know hypothesis class if you
don't optimize properly you're not going
to find the element of that you know
hypothesis class that fulfills your your
goals question the function the feature
function is extracting features from the
input since that self is a function of
them you can assume that your weight
would be able to question is if so
you're defining a function fee why this
is fixed and then learning sets weights
and together jointly they specify a
particular function or predictor don't
choose be appropriately you're limiting
the space they will be able to predict
yeah but so I'm wondering why but miners
my intuition tells me that the whole
point of learning is that the regardless
of the fee that you choose the actual
model that you choose would be able to
you know learn the function fee that you
would have picked Oh a so the question
is does doesn't learning kind of
compensate and just figure out the fee
that you would have picked so the answer
is short answer is no that the fee is
really kind of a bottleneck here for
example it just if you define fee to be
X so that's the linear function when
your function is all you're gonna get
right so if your data that moves around
in a sinusoidal way you're just gonna
like fit a line through that and you'll
get no horrible accuracy and no amount
of learning can you know fix that the
only way to fix that is by changing your
new feature representation W
so yes so all this assumes that W we're
talking about linear predictors okay but
of course the same general idea applies
to any sort of function family neural
nets the arcade so they're equivalent
there would be not just the feature map
but also the neural net architecture is
a constraint on what kind of things you
can express if you have them you're only
a two layer neural network then there's
just some things that you just you know
with or with a fixed size there's just
some things you just can't question I
thought it is more of a question of why
the form feature ization rather than
taking in the raw data you have like a
neural net it's still a function of
linear classifiers but it has enough
complexity that it can describe
nonlinear behavior yeah so the question
is why bother doing feature in
engineering has a neural Nets kind of
basically solve that so to some extent
an amount of feature engineering you
have to do today is know much less one
thing that I think it's still important
to think about in feature engineering is
it's really think about is what sources
of information you want to know predict
for example if you want to predict you
know this you know some property about
your movie review you know what what the
part of the first-order bits are like
what even goes into that does it the
texts go into that you have metadata do
you have other star ratings and those
are no features you can there's I guess
no such thing as like raw because
there's always some code that takes you
know the the you know the world and
distills it down into something that's
fits in memory so that's you can think
about as feature extraction yeah okay
one last question too many features
yeah yeah um so the question is why
don't you just make fee as large as
possible to throw on all the features
and overfitting is you know one of the
main concerns there which you know we'll
come back to in the next lecture
[Music]
okay great questions so let's let's
actually skip over this so there's
another type of feature function you can
define but in interest sometime I guess
skip over that okay so now let's come
back to this question is linear well I
keep on saying you or linear predictors
what what what is linear right so
remember the prediction is driven by the
score right so here's a question is this
score linear in W yes right because what
is a you know a linear function it's
basically some kind of weighted
combination of your inputs okay so is it
linear in V of X by symmetry should be
because it's just a dot product so is it
linear in X no in fact this question
doesn't even make sense because thing
about X X remember was a string right
it's not a it's not even a number so and
that's when you know the answer should
be no because you know that doesn't it
there's a type error
okay so here's here's kind of the cool
thing now is you know these predictors
can be expressive nonlinear function and
decision boundaries of X you know in the
case where X is is actually a real
vector but the score is a linear
function of W okay so this is cool
because you know from a there's two
perspectives right from the point of
actually doing prediction you know
you're thinking about like well how does
this function operate on X and you can
get all sorts of you know crazy
functions coming out we just looked at
quadratic functions which is clearly
nonlinear but you can do all sorts of
crazy things
but from the point of view of learning
it doesn't care about X all it sees is
fee of X in a particular you're learning
ask the question how is this function
depend on W right because it's tuning W
and from that perspective it's a linear
function of W and you know for reasons
I'm not going to you know go into these
functions permit efficient learning
because the loss function becomes convex
which I'll that's all say about that
okay so so one kind of cool way to
visualize what's going on here is screen
you're going back to our circles example
so remember we want this two-dimensional
classification problem where the true
decision boundary is you know let's say
a circle so how do we fit that and what
does it mean for a linear thing because
when you think linear it's like should
be a line right so here's a kind of a
cool graphic so okay so here is these
points inside the circle and you know it
can't be classified but the point is
when you look at the feature map it
actually lifts these points into a
higher dimensional space now I'll have
three features right and and you know in
this higher dimensional space I can
actually things are linear I can slice
it with a kind of a knife and then you
know in that high dimensional space if
things are cut and what it induces in
the lower dimensional space is you know
this circle
[Music]
okay okay so hopefully that was a nice
visualization that shows how you can
actually get nonlinear machine functions
out of kind of essentially linear
machinery right so someone the next time
someone says well you know you know
linear classifiers they're really
limited and you really need neural nets
you know that's technically as false
because you actually get really
expressive models out of your neural
networks
OSR out of linear models the point with
neural networks it's not that they're
not you're more necessary more Express
that can be more expressive but the fact
that they have other advantages for
example the inductive bias that comes
with architectures and the fact that
they're more efficient when you go to a
more expressive models and so on okay so
so to kind of wrap up all things I want
to kind of do us you know simple
exercise so here's a task so imagine
you're doing a final project and you
want to predict you know whether two
consecutive messages in sums for forum
or a chat or where the second one is a
response to the first so it's binary
classification input is two messages and
you're asked to predict whether the
second is a response to the first okay
so we're going to go through this
exercise of coming up with you know
features that might be or feature
templates might be useful to pick out
properties of X my might be useful and
we're going to assume that we're dealing
with linear predictors okay so what are
some features that might be useful let's
um you know let's here so let's start
with a few okay so how about time
elapsed between the two messages that
useful feature or not I mean you say yes
okay so this information is definitely
good
once subtle point is that this time
elapsed is a single number and this
number is going to go into the score
kind of in a linear fashion okay so what
is what does that mean that means you
know if I double the time then the score
is going to or that contribution to a
score is going to like multiply by two
right so think about it it's it's kind
of like saying them as I increase the
time you know the it becomes you know
linearly more likely that I'm going to
be let's say not a response or a
response so this is you know maybe kind
of not what you want because you know
the difference from that perspective
like if you the time elapsed is like a
year then that really kind of dominates
the the score function and it's like
more more likely that it's going to be a
response than if it were like one minute
which is and not what you want yeah
question
[Music]
yeah so the question is can you
normalize it so you have to be careful
with normalization so you have if you
normalize let's say the span of like
over one year now now there's no
difference between like you know five
seconds and one minute because
everything gets squashed down to zero
right so one way to kind of approach
that is to you know disk or ties the
features so one trick that people often
do is if you have a numerical value
which you really kind of want to treat
kind of in a sensitive way you can kind
of break up into pieces so the feature
template would look something like time
elapses between blah and blah so you can
do things like okay is it between zero
seconds of five seconds and is it
between five seconds and like a minute
and between a minute and an hour and an
hour and a year or something and then
after that it doesn't matter because
that will give you kind of more it's
it's more domain knowledge that tells
you kind of what things to look out for
the difference between let's say a year
and a year plus two seconds is really
you know it doesn't matter right where's
the difference between one second and
five seconds might be significant so
this is all - a long way of saying you
know if you're using a linear
classifiers or even if you're using
neural networks I think it's really
important to think about how your raw
features are kind of entering the system
and think about like if I change this
feature by like scaling it up does the
prediction change in a way that you know
I expect yeah yeah question
the second feature there
what prevents us from hitting let's say
if we have temple of Jupiter sages from
30 to 40 seconds and any soul what
prevents us from hitting just the entire
yeah so the question if you have every
possible range isn't that like an
infinite number of features so there's
two answers to that one is that even if
you did that you might still be okay
because there's probably some if you
think about like discretizing this space
it is your time elapsed time elapsed and
you're basically saying for every bucket
I'm gonna have a feature I mean it is
true that you have a empty number you
know features but you know at some point
you might just cut it off and if you
didn't cut it off and use sparse feature
representation you don't have to have a
preset you know maximum because remember
most of these features are going to be
zero because the chances of some data
point being like you know 10 years is
going to be essentially you know another
answer is that in general when you have
features that are have multiple time
scales you want to kind of space it out
kind of logarithmically so you know 1 to
2 2 to 4 4 to 8 so that you can have
both kind of sensitivity in the
libertines but also kind of cover a
large you know magnitude
yeah back this is my little learn like
how did this besides the features make
it the most informative question is is
it possible to learn how to discretize
the the features there are there's
definitely more automatic things you can
do besides you know just like span
specifying them at some level though you
have to kind of input the value in a
form like if you've inputted it into X
versus let's say log of X those choices
often can make a big difference but if
you use more expressive models like
neural networks you can you know
mitigate some of this yeah I see the
value changing time elapsed from a
number to range whatever you want to
retain a miracle value for future yeah a
good question so when would you actually
want to not discretize it so there are
essentially when you expect kind of the
scale of that feature to really kind of
matter in in the Sun in some sense so
certainly when you think that some
things behave linearly then you just
want to preserve the linear or if you
think that it behaves quadratically then
you want to keep the feature but also
add like a squared term to it okay I
want to maybe move on these are all good
questions happy to discuss more offline
so some other features might include the
first message contains blank or blank as
a string right so maybe things like you
know question marks are more indicative
of you know things being the second
message me or swans second message
contains certain words two messages both
contain a particular word
you know there's cases where it doesn't
really it's not the presence in absence
of particular words in the in individual
messages but like the fact that they
both share a common word you know that
might be useful here's another feature
which is you know two messages have the
sum number of common words together so
this feature is kind of interesting
because it's there's you know for
example you look at this feature it's
how the number of when I say feature I
actually mean feature template so for
this feature template there are many
many features one for possibly any
number of words and this again leads to
cases where you might have a lot of you
know sparsity and you might not have
enough data to fit all the features
whereas this one is very compact that
says I just have to look at the number
of overlaps so the the two messages
might contain a word I've never seen
before but I know it's the same word and
I can kind of recognize that pattern so
you know there's quite a bit of things
you can do to play around with features
that capture you know the intuitions
about what's might be relevant to your
task question that one we want to do
like dimensionality reduction so
question is when you have a lot of
sparse features do you want to do
dimensionality reduction not necessarily
so in terms of computation having sparse
features that doesn't necessarily mean
that it's going to be you know really
slow because there's efficient ways of
representing sparse features in terms of
you know expressivity one thing that in
a lot of NLP applications you actually
do want a lot of features and you can
have a lot more features than you might
think you can handle
and because you really wanted the first
orbit is just to you know be expressive
enough to even fit the data okay let me
move on since you know I'm running short
on time
okay so summary so far you know we're
looking at features we can define these
feature templates which organize these
features in a kind of meaningful way
then we talked about hypothesis classes
which are are defined by features and
this defines what is possible out of
from learning and all this is in the
context of linear classifiers which
incidentally can actually produce these
nice nonlinear decision boundaries so at
this point you can actually have kind of
enough tools to you know do a lot but in
the next section I want to talk about
neural networks because these are even
more expressive models which can be you
know more powerful one thing I often
recommend is that you know when you're
given a problem you always try this
simplest thing I will always try kind of
a linear classifier and just just see
where it gets because sometimes you'd be
surprised at how far you can get with
linear classifiers and then and then go
and kind of increase the complexity as
you need it I know there's sometimes a
temptation to you know try the fancy new
shot you know hammer but sometimes
keeping it simple is you know really
really good
okay so neural nets there's some couple
ways of motivating this one motivation
is know comes from the brain I'm going
to use a kind of a slightly different
motivation which comes from
kind of this idea of decomposing a
problem you know in two parts right so
this is a somewhat contrived example but
hopefully it'll allow us to build up the
intuitions for you know what's going on
in a neural network okay so suppose I am
building some sort of system to detect
whether two cars are going to collide
okay so the way it works is I have this
car at position x1 and it's you know
driving this way and then I have another
car at position x2 and it's driving this
way and I want to determine whether it's
safe which is positive or it's if it's
gonna collide okay and let's suppose for
simplicity that the true function is as
follows okay so just measuring whether
the distance is at least one apart now
this is kind of a little bit you know
like what we did in the last lecture
where we suppose there was a true
function and then see if learning can
recover that we're in practice obviously
we don't know that true function but
this is for kind of pedagogical purposes
okay so just kind of making sure we
understand what function we're talking
about so if X 1 is 1 and X 2 is 3 kind
of like that on the board then you're
plus 1 so this is like driving in the
u.s. this is like driving in the UK and
that's fine too but if you're you know
too close together then that's bad news
ok all right so let's think about
decomposing the problem right because if
you look at this you know this this
could be a kind of a complicated you
know function but let's try to break it
down into kind of linear functions right
because at the end of the day neural
networks are just a bunch of linear
functions with which are stitched
together with some non-linearity so like
there are the kind of linear components
that are critical to neuro that's okay
so one sub problem is detecting if car
one is to the far right of
- okay so excellent as x2 is greater
than equal to one another problem is
testing whether car two is a far right
of car one and then and then you can put
these together by saying if at least one
of them is you know one then I'm going
to predict safe otherwise they would
predict not safe okay so here's a kind
of concrete example so 4 1 3 car 2 is a
far-right of car 1 so that's a 1 you add
these up take the sign that's plus 1 in
the opposite direction it's still fine
and in this this case both H 1 and H 2
are 0 so that's bad news okay
so this is just kind of trying to take
this expression which is true function
and kind of write it in a kind of more
modular way where you have different
pieces correspond to different
competitions okay so now we could just
write this down obviously to solve this
problem but that we are in knew what the
right answer is but suppose we didn't
know what the true function is and we
just had data so so we don't actually
know what these functions are so can we
kind of learn learn these functions
automatically so what I'm going to do is
we're going to define a feature vector
now of X which is going to be a1 x1 x2
okay and then I'm going to rewrite this
intermediate sub problem on this follow
so X 1 is X 2 greater than 1 is going to
be represented as this vector v1 dot V
of X where v1 is minus 1 plus 1 minus 1
so you could you pause for a second you
can verify that this is x1 minus x2 you
know greater than equal to 1 okay so
this is just another way of writing you
know what we wanted in terms of this
like dot product and you can see kind of
how this is maybe moving more towards
something that looks more general yeah
so they're cleaner why is there is this
one here so this one typically is known
as a bias term which allows you to not
just you know threshold on zero but
threshold on how many arbitrary number
so in the linear classifiers that I have
you know talked about I've kind of swept
it under the rug generally you always
have a bias term that allows you to kind
of modulate how likely you're going to
predict one versus minus one okay so you
can also do it for h2 it's the same
thing but just you know we're switching
the roles of x1 x2 and Elsa for the sine
of final sign prediction you can write
it as follows
now these are just weights on h1 and h2
ok so now here is the the kind of the
punchline is no fraud neural network
we're just going to leave v1 v2 and W as
unknown quantities that we're going to
try to fit through training right we
motivated this problem by saying ok in
this case there's some choice of V 1 V 2
W that works but now we're kind of
generalizing if we didn't know this
quantities we just leave them as
variables and we can actually still fit
fit these parameters ok so before we
were just tuning W and now we're tuning
both V and W V specifies the choice of
the hidden problems that we're
interested in and W governs how do we
take the results of the hidden problems
and come to a final prediction okay so
there's one problem here which is that
if you look at the gradient of H one
with respect to V one it happens to be
zero okay so if you look at the
horizontal axis is V 1 dot V of X
Viroqua access is h1 that function is
looks like the step function right
because indicator function of some
quantity greater equals zero it's one
over here zero over here
and remember we don't like zero
gradients because SGG doesn't work so
the solution here is to take some
sandpaper and you you know sand out this
function to smooth it out and then you
get something that is you know
differentiable so the logistic function
is this function which is a smooth out
version of this which rises so it
doesn't hit 1 or 0 ever but it becomes
extremely close but it kind of goes up
in the in the middle and you can think
about this as a differentiable or I
guess a smooth version of the step
function okay so kind of behaves and
looks like the step function it serves
kind of the same intuition that you're
trying to test whether some quantity is
greater than 0 but it doesn't have 0
gradients anywhere ok and you can double
check if you take the derivative then
this is actually has this kind of really
interesting nice form which is the value
of the function times 1 minus the value
of the function and the value function
never hits 0 so this quantity never hit
0 ok so so now we can define no knots in
contrast to linear functions so remember
in linear functions we can visualize it
as inputs go in and each of the inputs
gets weighted by some W and you get the
score ok so this is a linear for what a
linear function looks like now neural
networks with one hidden layer
and two hidden units one to looks
something like this where you have these
intermediate hidden units which are the
sigmoid function applied or the logistic
function in this case and to be concrete
apply to this wave vector V J times V of
X so H 1 is going to be taking the input
multiplying by a vector and you get some
number here and then you send it through
this logistic function to get some
number and then finally you take the
output of H 1 H 2 and you take the dot
product with respect to W and then you
get the final score ok so again the
intuition is that neural nets are trying
to break down the problem into a set of
no sub problems where you the sub
problems are the kind of the result of
these intermediate computations and you
can think about these as you know each
one is really kind of output of a mini
linear classifier H 2 is output of a
mini linear classifier and then you're
taking those outputs and then you're you
know sticking them through another
linear class who are in getting the
score so this is what I mean by you know
at the end of the day it's kind of
linear classifiers packaged up and
strung together and the expressive power
comes from the kind of the composition
yeah question
[Music]
H sub J when there's like no feet the
question how do you get H sub J when
there's multiple fees there's only one
fee of X Oh so this is this is a first
component of V of X so this vector
there's this is a three dimensional
vector which is V of X and it has
[Music]
function of yeah yeah so that's what
kind of my next point which is that one
way you can think about it is that the H
J's are actually just you know features
which are learn automatically from data
as opposed to having a fixed set of your
features fee right because at this layer
w/o it ceases these you know HS which
are coming through which look like you
know features and for deeper neural
networks you kind of just keep on
stacking this so you know this output of
one set of classifiers becomes the
features to the next layer and then the
output of that class or it becomes the
features to the next layer and so on and
the intuition for you know deeper
networks is that you know as you proceed
you can derive more abstract you know
features for example images you start
with pixels and then you find kind of
edges and then you define kind of object
parts and then now you define kind of
things which are closer to the actual
classification problem yeah what an age
to develop the exact same value like do
you have to have a bias to start with oh
yeah this good question so why don't
each one and H to their basically end up
in the same place because you know
because of symmetry if you're not
careful that will happen so if you
initialize all your weights to zero and
or initialize these weights the same way
then they will be kind of moving Lux
lockstep so what is typically done as
you randomly initialize so they're kind
of you break
symmetry and then what the network is
going to do is it's trying to use learn
other it kind of automatically learns
the subproblems to be kind of
complementary because you're doing this
joint Laurie yeah how do I choose a
Sigma function so this is so in general
sigmoid functions are these or
activation functions are these nonlinear
functions so the important thing is it's
a nonlinear function I chose this
particular district function because
it's kind of the classic neural net and
it looks like the step function which is
kind of takes the score and outputs a
classification result I should you know
responsibly note that these are may be a
less in style than they used to be and
the the cool thing to do now is to use
what is called a rail U or a rectified
linear which looks like this and you
might ask like why this one well there's
no one reason but this this function has
less of a kind of this of gradient going
to zero problem it's also simpler
because of the Sun require Exponential's
but there's some I'm going to just leave
it at that what the benefit of this
function is pedagogical reasons and it's
a little bit of a throwback to ok yeah
if you read the notes in the lecture
slides there's more details on like why
you would might change
choose one versus another ok so now
we're kind of ready to do neuron that
learning alright so ok remember we have
this optimization problem it's it's a
training loss now it depends on both V
and W and the training loss remember is
average of losses of manger for examples
the loss of each of the example let's
say we're doing regression is the
squared difference between y and the
function value and remember the function
value is the summation over though the
weights at the last layer times activate
of the hidden layer and and that's
basically okay and now all I have to do
is compute this gradient so you look at
this and you say okay well you know if
you get you know have enough scratch
paper you can probably like work it out
I'm going to show you a different way to
do this without grinding through the
chain rule so this is going to be based
on the computation graph which will give
you insight more additional insight into
the kind of a structure of computations
and visualize what it means what does a
gradient kind of mean in some sense and
it also happens that this computation
graphs is really at the foundation of
all these modern deep learning
frameworks like tensor flow and pi torch
so this is a real thing now it turns out
that you know when I've taught this it
many people still kind of prefer to
grind out the math I can't really tell
why except for maybe you're more
familiar with that and so I would
encourage everyone to kind of at least
try to think about the computation graph
as a way to understand your gradient
even though initially it might not be no
faster and it's not to say that you
always have to draw a graph to compute
gradients but you know doing it a few
times might give you an additional
insight that you wouldn't otherwise get
ok so here we go
so functions we can think about them as
just boxes right the boxes you have some
inputs going in and then you get some
output that's all function is ok and a
partial derivatives or no gradients
that's the question the following
question how much does the output change
if the input changes a little bit okay
so for example if we have this function
that just computes 2 times n 1 plus n 2
in 3 you ask the question like you take
input 1 and you just add a little bit
Absalon so like point zero zero
you ask hmm and then and you read out
the output and you say what happens to
the output well in this case the output
changed by two epsilon additively okay
so then you conclude that the gradient
of this function with respect to n1 is
is y 2 right because the Grady is kind
of the amplification if I put in epsilon
then I got 2 Epsilon out there
graininess 2 or the partial derivative
so okay let's do this one so if I add
epsilon 2 into then I simple algebra
shows I get a change in in 3 epsilon so
what's the partial with respect to in 2
[Music]
in 3 right ok good so you know you could
have done the you know basic calculus
and gone that but I really kind of want
to stress the kind of interpretation of
you know perturbing inputs and
witnessing the output because I think
that's a useful interpretation ok so now
all functions are well not all functions
are made out of building blocks but most
of the functions that we're interested
in in this class are going to be made
out of this these five pieces ok and so
for each of these pieces it's you know
it's a function it has inputs a and B
and you pump these things in and you get
some output there so this is plus minus
x max and the logistic function ok so on
these edges I'm going to write down in
green the the partial derivative with
respect to the input that's going into
function okay so let's do this so if I
have the function a plus B the partial
derivative with respect to a is 1 and
the partial derivative with respect to B
is 1 ok and if you have - then it's 1
and minus 1 if you have x then the
partial is B and a okay everyone follow
so far okay okay so max what is this
this is oh maybe a little bit you know
trickier so remember we kind of
experience the max last time so in the
max example you have just refresh so so
remember the last time we have that we
saw the max in the context of the the
hinge loss right so you have the max of
these two functions which is this which
means that you know let's say one is one
is a and the other is B so if a is
greater than B then the then we need to
take the derivative with sorry then okay
let me do it this way okay ignore that
thing on the board so I just have max a
of B okay so suppose a is 7 and B is 3
okay so max Amb and let's say this is 7
and this is 3 so that means a is greater
than B so now if I change a by a little
bit then that change is going to be
reflected by and the output of a max
function right because this this region
is small and it doesn't matter and in
this case if I change B by a little bit
then this output change no because like
you know three point one two point nine
it's all the output doesn't change so
the grading is going to be zero there so
the max of a function it's partial
derivatives look like this so if a is
greater than B then this is going to be
a 1 if a is less than B this is going to
be a zero and you know conversely over
here if a B is greater than a then this
is gonna be a 1 if P is less than a then
this is gonna be a zero okay so the
partial of maximum is always 1 or 0
depending on this particular you know
condition okay and then the logistic
function this is just a fact you can
derive it in your you know free time but
I had on a previous slide it's just like
the sigmoid logistic function times 1
minus a logistic function okay so now
you have these building blocks now you
can compose and you can build castles
out of them it turns out like all
basically all functions that you see in
you know you know deep learning are just
basically bear that build build all of
these blocks and how do you compose
things there's this nice thing called
the chain rule which says that if you
think about input going to foreign
function and that output going to input
a new function then the partial
derivative with respect to the input of
the output is just a product of the
partial derivative changes like you know
I think about amplification so for this
function amplifies by two times and this
amplified this function amplifies by
five then that total application is
going to be two times five
okay all right so now let's take an
example we're going to do binary
classification with a hinge loss I'm
just as a warm-up and I'm gonna draw
this computation graph and then compute
the partial derivative with respect to W
okay so what is this graph so I have W
times V of X that's a score times y
that's a margin one minus margin max of
1 minus margin zero is the loss okay so
now for every edge I can draw the
partial derivative okay so here remember
the partial derivative here is left hand
side greater than you know the right the
right branch so one minus margin greater
than zero four minus this is a minus 1/4
times this is going to be whatever is
over here for this times it's gonna be
one of ours over here and by the chain
rule if you multiply what's on all the
edges then you get the gradient of the
loss with respect to W okay so this is
kind of a graphical way of doing what
you know probably what I did last time
which is if the margin is less than
greater than 1 then it's everything zero
if the margin is less than one deny
perform this particular update okay so
in the interest of time I'm not going to
do it for the simple neural network will
do this in section but you know I had a
high level you basically do the same
thing you multiply all the blue edge the
edges and you get the partial
derivatives okay so so now you know
we've kind of done everything kind of
manually I want to kind of systemize
this and talk about an algorithm called
back propagation that allows you to
compute gradients for arbitrary
computation graph that means any kind of
function that you can build out of these
building blocks you can actually just
get the
so you know one nice thing about these
packages like a PI torch or tensorflow
is that you actually don't have to
compute the derivatives on your own you
should be the case that you know before
these people would have to crank
implement these derivatives by by hand
which is really tedious and error-prone
and part of why it's been so easy to
kind of develop new models is that all
that's done for you automatically okay
so the back propagation is going to
compute two types of values a forward
value and a backward value so fi for
every node I is the simply the value of
that expression tree and the backward
value GI is going to be the partial
derivative with respect to output of
that the value of that node okay so for
example fi here is going to be W 1 times
Sigma V 1 times V of X and G of that
node is going to be the basically the
product of all these edges basically how
much does this no change the output at
that final ad at the very top okay so
the algorithm itself is is you know
quite straightforward there's a forward
pass which computes all the FIS and then
there's a backward pass that computes
all the G is so in the forward pass you
start from the leaves and you go to the
root and you compute each of these
values kind of recursively where the
computation depends on you know the sub
expressions and then the backward pass
you similarly have a recurrence that
gives you the value of a particular a GI
of a particular node is equal to the GI
of its parent times whatever is on this
edge okay so it's like you take a
forward pass you fill in all the FIS and
then you take a backward pass and you
feel a lot of G eyes that you care about
okay all right so a section will go
through this and detail I realize this
might have been a little bit quick one
quick note about optimization is that
now you have all the tools that you can
do you can run s to D on it which
doesn't really care about whether you're
you're you know what the function is
it's just like a function you have it
you can compute the gradient that's all
you need but one kind of an important
thing to note is that just because you
can compute a gradient doesn't mean you
optimize the function so for linear
function it turns out if you define
these Lost's functions on top you get
these convex functions or convex
functions are these functions that you
can hold in your hand and it and they
have a one global minimum and so if you
think about SPG it's going going
downhill you'll converge to the global
minima and you solve the problem
whereas neural nets it turns out that
the loss functions are non convex which
means I if you try to go downhill you
might get stuck in local optimum in a
general optimization of neural nets is
hard in practice people somehow manage
to do it anyway and it works there's a
gap between theory and practice which is
active area of research okay so in one
minute I'm two nearest neighbors it will
actually be fine because nearest
neighbors is really simple so you can do
it in one minute
so here goes so let's throw away
everything we knew about linear
classifier Oh nuts
here's algorithm your training is you
store your training examples that's it
and then the predictor of a particular
example that you get is you're going to
go through all the training examples and
find the one which is closest has an
input which is closest to your your
input X prime and then you're just going
to train you're gonna return my ok so in
the intuition here is that similar
examples similar inputs should get
similar outputs okay
so here's an example so suppose we're in
two dimensions and you're doing
classification
and you have Plus over here let's do
this Plus and you have your - yeah okay
so if you are asking what is the label
asides at that point it should be plus
because this is closer this is should be
- this region should be - this should be
plus and you know one kind of cool thing
is that if where's the decision boundary
so if you look at the point that is
equidistant from these and draw a
perpendicular that's the decision
boundary there same thing over here and
so you have basically carves out this
region where this is - and everything
here is plus okay in general this is
what I've drawn is an instance of a
Voronoi diagram which if you were given
a bunch of points they define regions of
points which are closest to that point
and everything in a particular region
like this yellow region is assigned
those same label as on this point here
and this is what is called a
nonparametric a model which means that
the number it doesn't mean that there's
no parameters it means that the number
of parameters is not fixed the more
points you have the more kind of each
point is its own parameter so you can
actually fit really expressive models
I'm using that it's very simple but it's
a kind of computation expensive because
you have to store your entire training
examples okay so we looked at three
different models and you know there's a
saying that well I guess in school you
there's three things study sleep and
party or something you have to only pick
two of them well so for learning it's
kind of the same it can either be fast
to predict for linear models and neural
nets you can be easy to learn for the
linear of models and nearest neighbors
or it could be powerful for example like
neural networks and nearest neighbors
but there's always some sort of
compromise and exactly a would method
you choose will depend on kind
what you care about okay see you next
time
[Music]